Diese innovative Idee hier könnte tatsächlich
irgendwann mal das Ende von Hungersnöten
weltweit bedeuten!
Ein Forschungsteam aus Finnland hat es geschafft,
mit speziell entwickelten Bioreaktoren nachhaltige
Protein-Mahlzeiten herzustellen.
Und zwar aus Kohlendioxid, ein paar Nährstoffen,
Mikroorganismen und ein bisschen Sonnenlicht
- und das emissionsfrei.
Clixoom Science & Fiction Hier gibt es täglich
Videos rund um Science, abonniert den Kanal,
nur dann verpasst ihr kein Video.
herzlich willkommen!
WOW!
Irre Geschichte.
Nahrungsmittel aus Licht und Kohlendioxid.
Die benötigten Bioreaktoren sind zudem - anders
als die Landwirtschaft - unabhängig von externen
Umwelteinflüssen wie dem Wetter.
Und Kaum zu glauben, aber die entwickelten
Bioreaktoren sind gerade einmal so groß wie
eine Tasse Kaffee.
Dort drin hat das Forschungsteam aus Finnland
tatsächlich aus einer wässrigen Lösung
eine kleine Menge an festem Material gewonnen.
Konkret wurden dafür Mikroorganismen, freies
Kohlendioxid und Wasser benötigt.
Durch Solar-Energie kam es zur Elektrolyse.
Ihr kennt das vielleicht aus dem Chemieunterricht:
Bei diesem Prozess bewirkt Elektrizität eine
Aufspaltung komplexer Substanzen.
Zwei Wochen dauerte es, bis die Bioreaktoren
mit der Produktion fertig waren.
Das Ergebnis: Eine pulvrige Biomassen, und
konkret etwa ein Gramm Protein-Pulver, das
zur Hälfte aus Proteinen, also Eiweißen
besteht.
Jeweils weitere ein Viertel verteilen sich
auf Kohlenhydrate sowie auf Nukleinsäuren
und Fette.
Die so produzierte Biomasse könnte sehr vielfältig
genutzt werden: Zum einen wie schon erwähnt
als Nahrungsmittel.
Dazu einer der beteiligten Forscher Juha-Pekka
Pitkänen: “In Zukunft kann die Technologie
beispielsweise in Wüsten und andere Gebiete
mit häufig auftretenden Hungersnöten transportiert
werden.
Eine mögliche Alternative ist so etwas wie
ein Hausreaktor, also eine Art Haushaltsgerät,
mit dem die Verbraucher das benötigte Protein
produzieren können".
Anders als die Landwirtschaft wäre man hiermit
nicht durch Umwelteinflüsse wie etwa das
Wetter eingeschränkt.
Dazu der Wissenschaftler Jero Ahola: "Im Vergleich
zur traditionellen Landwirtschaft benötigt
diese Produktionsmethode keine bestimmten
Standort-Voraussetzungen.
Sowas wie die richtige Temperatur, Feuchtigkeit
oder eine bestimmte Bodenart.
(...) Die Methode erfordert zudem keine Schädlingsbekämpfung”.
Nur erneuerbare Energien, wie beispielsweise
in Form von Solarenergie, müssen verfügbar
sein.
Zudem sind die Bioreaktoren nur klein und
nehmen nicht viel Platz weg.
Da die Prozesse ausschließlich in den Reaktoren
selbst stattfinden, gibt es auch keine negativen
Auswirkungen auf die Umwelt.
Der Herstellungsprozess ist nach Angaben des
Forschungsteams tatsächlich komplett nachhaltig.
Anders als die Landwirtschaft in Deutschland
Grünflächen werden in Ackerland umgewandelt
und Düngemittel en masse eingesetzt: All
das ist nach Angaben des Bundesumweltamtes
zweitgrößte Ursache von Treibhausgasen.
Und das Protein könnte auch noch durch die
Verarbeitung zu Tierfutter als mögliche Problemlösung
des weltweiten Hungerproblems beitragen.
Im besten Fall könnten so die derzeit für
Landwirtschaft genutzten Flächen frei gemacht
werden - beispielsweise für die Forstwirtschaft.
Doch auch in einem ganz anderen Bereich könnte
das so hergestellte Protein eingesetzt werden.
In der Raumfahrt nämlich.
Schließlich entspricht es in seiner Zusammensetzung
einem Grundnahrungsmittel - eine wichtige
Voraussetzung bei langen Weltraum-Aufenthalten.
Doch es gibt auch noch Herausforderungen,
die das Forschungsteam angehen muss: Wie bereits
erwähnt, braucht es bislang zwei Wochen,
um gerade einmal ein Gramm zu produzieren.
Heißt also: Deutlich größere Mengen müssen
her.
Dafür muss das Konzept des Reaktors optimiert
werden - genauso wie die Steuerung des Prozesses
an sich.
Doch das Forschungsteam aus Finnland ist optimistisch
und will zukünftig ein Massenprodukt daraus
machen und somit auch eine Kommerzialisierung
möglich machen.
Wow!
Das Video haben wir übrigens zuerst in englisch
veröffentlicht.
Wenn ihr Premieren dort nicht verpassen wollt,
dann abonniert den Kanal hier.
Einfach draufklicken und hier geht es weiter
mit: Nanobots become reality - robots in your
own body!
Bis dann, bleibt dran!